there's some news out today about how
many jobs or at least the claims of how
many jobs have been created so far from
the stimulus plan and at first the
numbers look impressive the
administration said that
650 000 jobs were created from
150 billion dollars of stimulus spending
so far so let me write that down
650 000 jobs
jobs
from
billion that's a thousand
million
from 150 billion of spending so what
does that turn out to on a per job basis
let's see let's get a calculator out
here so if i spend 150
that's a thousand
it's 150 million right that's 150
million 150
billion if i spend 150 billion dollars
to get 650 000 jobs let me just divide
by six hundred and fifty
thousand
i get to
two hundred and thirty thousand dollars
per job
so that is equal to
two hundred 230
per job
which is which are claimed to be saved
so you know obviously they're not just
outright paying the salary these people
were adding some value to begin with so
these were clearly very good jobs
so two hundred thirty thousand dollars i
think is fair to say then is more than
the majority of us make so these are
very good jobs
very good
jobs now there's a further claim that at
least another 350 000 jobs were created
from
189 billion dollars of tax relief so
it's we got a 189 billion dollars less
to the government and that created 350
000 jobs so let's see what that turns
out to be
we have 350 000 jobs
from
billion that's 189 000 that's 189
million that's 189 billion in tax relief
in tax relief
so let's see what that is on a per job
basis get the calculator out
and so if we have
000 that's a million
that's 189 billion right 189 thousand
189 there you go that's 189 billion so
you divide that by 350 000 jobs one two
three
and you get 540 000
per job
so this is equal to
540 000
per job
which are even better than the 230 000
jobs that we we were able to save with
150 billion dollars
so clearly some very highly paid people
are being able to keep their jobs by
virtue of the stimulus package